el vídeo pasado fue muy abstracto y
general use una fx una g de una hdt
entonces lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es fijar las ideas haciendo un
ejemplo concreto vamos a tomar
efe de x igual al producto de x a x
borge ahora supongamos que también
tenemos una trayectoria en el plano x
que dada como sigue déjame llamarle a
esta curva c y vamos a suponer que está
dada por las siguientes coordenadas x
igual a coseno de t y que igual a seno
de t conforme se mueve te vamos a
obteniendo puntos en el plano xy pero te
tengo que decir en donde se mueve t el
límite inferior va a ser cero lo voy a
escribir aquí a la derecha cero es menor
o igual a
atte
y esto es menor o igual que vamos a
ponerlo en radiales y medios si fuera en
grados serían 90 grados bajo esta de
aquí es la curva a lo mejor reconozcas
inmediatamente cómo se ve una curva de
este estilo pero lo voy a dibujar
rápidamente para poder visualizar esta
cosa de aquí va entonces esta curva
vamos a dibujarlo rápidamente si voy
déjame hacerlo con otro color
voy a poner aquí mi eje y entonces de
aquí voy a poner el eje
x cuando te vale 0 que obtenemos tenemos
x igual a coseno de 0 cosenos de cero es
1 y es igual a seno de cero senos de
cero es cero entonces para t igual a
cero obtenemos este punto de aquí es
decir x igual a coser no de cero igual a
seno de cero o lo que es lo mismo el
punto 10 t igual a cero ahí está para
cuando usted es igual a pi medios que
obtenemos coseno depp y medios a ver
este es el ángulo
jose no de pie entre 20 y seno de pie
entre 2 es igual a 1 entonces obtenemos
el punto 01 es este de aquí para t igual
a ti medios a lo mejor ya te diste
cuenta que lo que vamos a dibujar es el
primer cuadrante del círculo unitario
para cuando te es igual a cuartos vamos
a obtener el punto x igual a igual a 1
entre raíz de dos puedes verificar lo
por tu cuenta
cuando tratemos todo que nos queda pues
queda la parte superior derecha del
círculo unitario
y además va a estar recorrido en esta
dirección conforme se mueve de 0 a 2 ay
le pongo c ahora pues no estamos aquí
simplemente para graficar una ecuación
paramétrica lo que queremos hacer es
levantar una cosa como una tipo reja
sobre esta curva hasta la superficie
aquí arriba ya preparé unos dibujos para
visualizarlo mejor vamos para cada
entonces aquí tenemos dos dibujos de la
misma situación va son exactamente lo
mismo solo que uno está rotado con
respecto al otro entonces vamos al de la
izquierda en este de la izquierda voy a
marcar aquí el eje x ahí está el eje x
aquí atrás está el eje y el eje vertical
es el eje z va a estar el uno por aquí y
por acá también está el uno y entonces
vamos a dibujar esta curva sobre el
plano xy de mi gráfica entonces quedaría
algo de este estilo déjame dibujarlo ahí
va listo acuérdate que eso está sobre el
plano xy está de aquí es exactamente la
misma gráfica fx y igual xy voy a
ponerlo
efe x
es igual a xy que también es igual que
esta de acá simplemente está rota da y
en esta segunda aquí tenemos el eje x
simplemente está rotado digamos como
unos 30 grados más o menos este de acá
es el eje y y fíjate aquí arriba sube el
eje z va la curva se vamos a dibujarla
en el segundo en el segundo diagrama y
nos queda algo de este estilo cuando
usted es igual a cero aquí tenemos este
puntito que se empieza a mover y
conforme se mueve llega hasta acá hasta
el punto cero uno que corresponde a
cuando te es igual a pi medios lo que
queremos hacer es encontrar el área que
queda en la cortina que está entre estas
dos superficies es decir vamos a ir
bajando algunos hilos por aquí para
formar una cortina o si quieres pensarlo
más bien como una pared déjame pintarla
con otro color para que quede sombreada
bonito aquí le voy a poner naranja ahora
quiero poner más naranja
ok voy a tomar otro color a ver vamos a
sombrear lo con otras líneas verticales
más o menos por aquí y lo que queremos
hacer es encontrar el área de esta pared
que está entre la base definida por la
curva y el techo que está definido por
esta superficie entonces ya tenemos dos
gráficas ya tenemos más o menos unidades
que tenemos que hacer acordémonos del
vídeo pasado para ver cómo le hacíamos
la idea es tomar un pequeño cambio en la
longitud de arco y multiplicar ese
pequeño cambio por la altura y la altura
pues justamente está dada por el valor
de la función este pequeño cambio lo
vamos a llamar de ese y la altura es
simplemente es fx y después vamos a
tener que hacer una suma infinita desde
t igual a 0 hasta que igual a pi medios
o sea una integral y eso debería de
darnos el área de esta pared va vámonos
a las cuentas lo que acabamos de decir
es que hay que tomar la integral desde t
igual a 0 hasta que igual a pi entre 2
tiene mucho sentido verdad porque ya
todo va a quedar en términos de té de fx
y aunque bueno justo por lo que acabo de
decir como ya vamos a tener todo en
términos de té vamos avanzando hacia eso
entonces vamos a poner fx explícitamente
que es xy ahorita lo cambiamos por las
cosas de té y hay que multiplicar por el
pequeño cambio en la longitud de arco de
ese vamos a acordarnos que hacíamos en
el vídeo pasado en el vídeo pasado
encontramos que este pequeño cambio en
la longitud de arco es decir de ese
estaba dado por la siguiente fórmula
estaba dado por la raíz cuadrada de de x
entre dt o sea la derivada de x con
respecto a t al cuadrado más la derivada
de ella con respecto a t al cuadrado
y todo eso multiplicado por de t va
entonces vamos a reescribir nuestra
integral con esta nueva fórmula esta
expresión nos queda igual a la integral
desde t igual a 0 hasta te iguala y
medios
de xy ahora sí vamos a poner cuánto vale
x y cuánto vale ya vámonos a la
parametrización entonces en vez de poner
una equis tenemos que poner coseno de t
por qué pues porque justo sobre la curva
x vale coseno de t aquí le pongo coseno
de t va este de aquí es x no estoy
haciendo nada raro simplemente viene de
la parametrización va ahora pasemos al
valor de g hay que multiplicar por
cheques seno de t seno de t misma idea
esto de aquí vale ye porque lo único que
hice fue cambiar cada uno de ellos por
sus valores que nos da la
parametrización vamos a multiplicar por
d&s de esa es la raíz cuadrada de la
derivada de x con respecto a t todo eso
elevado al cuadrado más la derivada de y
con respecto a t elevado al cuadrado y
multiplicamos por un dt va entonces
tenemos que encontrar estas dos
derivadas podría parecer algo complicado
pero en realidad no lo es porque aquí
está xy aquí está y entonces simplemente
tenemos que encontrar las derivadas no
voy a escribir aquí abajo a la derecha
entonces sabemos que la derivada de x
con respecto a t es la derivada de
coseno con respecto a t y eso de ahí es
menos seno de t y por otro lado la
derivada de ella con respecto a la
derivada de ye con respecto a t es igual
a la derivada de seno con respecto a t
es decir es coseno dt en ba vamos a
sustituir en la raíz para ver que nos
queda entonces a ver acuérdate que
hacemos todo esto para encontrar el área
de esta cortina que abajo tiene la base
como la curva y la función es el techo
ok entonces reescribamos la integral nos
queda la integral desde cero hasta te
iguala pi medios
ba cambiamos al amarillo de coseno de t
por seno dt coseno porsche no
simplemente es x por d&s que es esta
expresión de aquí entonces vamos a
reescribir esto como la raíz de la
derivada de x con respecto a que es
menos seno de t - seno de t elevado al
cuadrado y luego sumamos la derivada de
ya con respecto a t que está aquí es
coseno de t elevado al cuadrado verdad
voy a aumentar un poco la raíz y todo
esto hay que multiplicarlo por bt déjame
copiar esta expresión aquí a la derecha
entonces vamos a ver qué es algo
realmente simple va entonces vamos a
hacer el menos 0 dt al cuadrado y
quitarle el signo lo voy a hacer por
aquí nos queda menos seno de t elevado
al cuadrado más coseno de t
elevado al cuadrado y eso de ahí es
igual a seno de t elevado al cuadrado
más coseno de t elevado al cuadrado
estas dos expresiones son exactamente lo
mismo porque simplemente este menos lo
elevamos al cuadrado y lo cancelamos va
fíjate que esto de aquí es la identidad
trigonométricas más fácil del mundo este
de aquí simplemente es uno va entonces
toda esta expresión que está dentro de
dentro de la raíz es igual a 1 entonces
tomar la raíz de 1 nos queda igual a 1 y
entonces toda esta expresión se
convierte en un 1
entonces esta expresión esta integral
que se veía muy difícil se simplifican a
la integral desde t igual a cero hasta t
igual a pi medios y déjame hacer un
pequeño cambio para que se vea más claro
el siguiente paso voy a intercambiar
coseno y seno y aquí voy a poner seno de
t multiplican
seno de 'the x coseno de t de t lo único
que hice fue que esta cosa la puse igual
a uno e intercambiar el orden de estos
dos para que el siguiente paso sea más
fácil de explicar ahora esta integral
pues fíjate hay un seno y un coseno y el
coste no es la derivada de seno entonces
tenemos una función y su derivada a lo
mejor te animes a hacer esta esta
integral de aquí por un cambio de
variable mentalmente pero yo lo voy a
hacer más más explícitamente para que
nos quede muy claro cómo quedan entonces
voy a proponer un valor de u voy a poner
igual a seno de t
y ahora tenemos que derivar con respecto
a te deum de t es igual a coseno de t y
si multiplicamos ambos lados por de t
siendo prácticos pero no precisamente
rigurosos nos queda que de eeuu es igual
a coseno de t de t excelente fíjate que
aquí tenemos una u y que coseno de este
x dt es igual a de uno entonces aquí
queda de un y vamos a poner que nos
queda en los límites de integración
cuando te es igual a cero nos estamos
haciendo esto porque tenemos que
cambiarlo a la integral de de algo con
pura verdad entonces cuando te es igual
a cero es seno de cero
entonces nos queda también igual a cero
y arriba nos queda pues a ver seno de
pime dioses en nueve y medios que es uno
y entonces en el límite superior debemos
poner uno es igual a uno va muy bien
pasemos lo demás en términos de eeuu
aquí tenemos una y entonces ponemos aquí
y en vez de con seno de tdt tenemos
simplemente de un esta de aquí es la
integral más fácil del mundo verdad
bueno
quizás es un poco más difícil que las de
las constantes pero igual está fácil nos
queda un medio de 1 al cuadrado
simplemente elevamos el exponente en 1 y
dividimos entre el exponente nuevo
entonces un medio de o al cuadrado
evaluado desde 0 hasta 1 ya nada más hay
que pasar esto a las cuentas numéricas
verdad es un medio de 1 al cuadrado
menos un medio de 0 al cuadrado va esto
que nos queda es un medio por 1 menos un
medio por 0 que 0 es un medio listo
hicimos todo este trabajo y obtuvimos
una respuesta bonita y sencilla entonces
el área de esta cortina el área de la de
la pared que marcamos aquí ya está hecha
por una integral de línea entonces nos
queda una aplicación muy bonita y que
nos quedó pues nos quedó igual a un
medio listo espero que te haya gustado
este ejemplo la verdad estuvo un poco
fácil en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
hacer uno un poco más complicado